we started the matt wall show in my car
we did the first many shows just like
that it was a low-tech low-budget lo-fi
operation back in those days and it was
just me in a random parking lot
screaming at my dashboard confusing all
the other walmart shoppers
and the worst thing is that no one ever
told me i had a terrible haircut back
then i don't know how my wife let me out
of the house like that but eventually
she invited me back into the house and
we moved into a home studio
and an odd thing started to happen is
that people started watching and
listening and we started to grow and
eventually we moved out here to
nashville and that's when things really
started to take off over the last year
thanks so much to all of you
we have become the fastest growing
conservative podcast in the country uh
one of the fact one of the one of the
biggest
news commentary podcasts in the country
one of the biggest podcast period we've
got the best documentary of the year
we've got a a lgbt best-selling
children's book we're saving abuelas
we're saving virginia we're doing all of
that but here's the great thing we're
just getting started